foreign
let's go out to Raleigh North Carolina
and talk to Jade what's up Jade
Hi how are you I mean
I could not be better how are you good
good
what's up
so um I guess just get straight to the
point Cannonball baby
yeah I've been doing really good in my
life I'm in a healthy relationship I've
like gone into a positive direction but
for some reason I just never forgive
myself for all the bad decisions I've
made in the past
and I just feel like I'm just always
angry with myself
what'd you do
um so I got into a really bad
relationship that kind of like destroyed
everything like my family it destroyed
me financially I married him knowing
that like he had a baby with my friend
he was always you know hiding things
behind my back lying to me and just
doing like there's like so many red
flags of why I should have never been
with him
and you know I finally made the decision
after I married him to divorce him
because I just couldn't take the
emotional
um mental abuse anymore the financial
abuse and I'm in a better like place
with my life now but every single time
like I do something well I'm like wow I
could have done this such a long time
ago if I had never made those bad
decisions and you would not be you would
not be near
the gangster that you are right now if
you had not been through that
yeah I don't really like that sometimes
sometimes I feel like very
I know
who taught you in your life that when
you're abused it's your fault
somebody taught you that yeah well how
did she teach you that
well like even if I could do everything
right and if something happens wrong she
finds some way to have even like I could
have done everything to prevent that
from happening if just something happens
wrong it's like you should have done X Y
and Z better you should have done this
and I've kind of always felt like
if I am not perfect or if I don't find a
way to make sure there is no mistakes
that I just I'm just a complete failure
and somehow over time her constant
criticism and critique and negativity
you've probably heard me use this
analogy but you were born with a
backpack a beautiful little girl where
were you born
um I was born in Okinawa
okay beautiful little girl in Okinawa
and make sure where your States the
states
and your mom just keeps dropping little
pebbles in your backpack every day why
are you wearing that you're too fat
don't fix your hair like that it makes
you look ugly you have a big forehead
and I'm just making stuff up I've never
seen you but just never stops why did
you do this is this the best you can you
couldn't have got a hundred you just got
a 98 it's stupid right little Pebble
little Pebble little pebble
and after a while that backpack gets
really freaking heavy doesn't it
yeah and after a while her words become
your words
so when you talk that way to yourself
that's not your voice that's your mom's
voice
Fair
yeah
now how many years ago was did you start
this relationship with this dude
so he was actually my high school
sweetheart so I've been with him for a
long time before I finally broke it off
because I just how old was he couldn't
handle it how old was he um
when we first met we were in our we were
in our teenage years and then finally
when we separated what was great about
him when you met him
like it was he cute was he funny was he
silly
yeah all of that
okay
were you 16 14 hold were you
I was 15 15.
here's homework assignment number one
I want you to write 15 year old Jade a
letter a handwritten letter with no book
paper and a pen
I want you to forgive her let her go she
was a kid
okay
if you met a 15 year old little girl how
old are you now
I'm 28. you met a 15 year old girl
who was just beating herself up because
her boyfriend was slowly taking her soul
from her and taking her innocence from
her and was slowly controlling her and
she was just telling me what a terrible
girlfriend she is what would you say to
her
that she shouldn't be in that
relationship yeah and you tell her hey
you're a kid chill out
you need to tell 15 year old Jade
that that boy was cute and that boy was
funny and she acted like every other 15
year old girl
and she had a crush on him and she went
on a date with him and then she fell in
love with him
and nobody could have predicted the
quicksand that you would have ended up
in
an abuse and Trauma and gaslighting and
psychosis all those things
wreak havoc on people
we find ourselves doing things we would
never do just to keep the peace for a
minute just to keep safety just to keep
whatever
and then your second letter I want you
to write
how old were you when you broke up with
this dude when you got divorced
it was
I want you to write 26 year old Jada
letter and tell her how proud of her you
are
for getting the courage to stand up for
getting the courage just to walk away
from getting the current from all of it
and be very specific in that letter you
did this and you did this
good for you
and then here's my big question for you
any of this
constant beating up on yourself
you talk to yourself in a way that you
would never let somebody talk to another
person that you love
if somebody at a bar talked to one of
your girlfriends the way you talk to
yourself you would hit them in the mouth
with a beer bottle
right I know you
so my question is is any of this
self-talk helping
is any of this helping you get where you
want to be
no
no because from the earliest age you can
remember
the one person who was supposed to be in
your corner all the time
declared war on you
and from as early as you can remember
the first guy who looked at you and said
I love you and I'll be here forever
was a piece of crap
yeah so it's easy for your body to think
oh this is what I'm worth all across the
board the most important woman my first
love all you see what I'm saying
so what you have to decide is
I'm done with this
Jade is an absolute gangster who's been
through hell and back and I got the
scars to prove it bring it on world
and Mom if you're going to continue to
criticize me then you are choosing to
not be in relationship with this
gangster
bye Felicia
hey new boyfriend
if you get an
ounce of dishonesty dude I'm a smoke
show I'm awesome I'm Jade
bye Felicia
great and when Jade starts talking to
Jade really bad negatively
I want you to keep a little Journal once
you start writing that crap down
and I want you to physically write it
down and physically draw life a line
through it and right underneath it lies
not true
or occasionally I probably shouldn't
eaten two uh McGriddles Fair
all right that's fair
you could Circle that one and say true
all right yeah
all right so I just talked a lot at you
tell me how you're feeling
um you feel a bit better about it um I
guess
I got kind of worried that like a lot of
these habits that I've kind of
picked up from all of that is kind of
like entering into my new relationship
too and I just don't want that to
transition there because I'm trying to
make remember that he's not my ex and
it's really hard for me so like here's
the way here's a way to overcome it
keep no secrets
here's what that means
does this new boyfriend does this new
person you're in a relationship with do
they know all your past
yeah okay so I want you to take him out
and say I like you have you said I love
you gross
all right yeah yeah
I don't want to wait away all right so
I want you to take him out and say I
love you
and I find in finding myself falling
into all patterns
I'm not gonna allow that to happen again
and if you love me you're gonna walk
alongside me here's what this means this
means I'm gonna have to practice
if you catch me with negative self-talk
I I'm asking you to call it up
if you at see me withdrawing I'm going
to ask you to reach out and grab my hand
and say I love you whatever it is that
you need in those moments
I want you to speak those needs out and
when you speak those needs out you're
gonna feel buck naked in in this and on
on the Taylor Swift stage in front of
all these you can feel so exposed right
because nobody's ever given a crap what
you need or want or feel
great and it's time
foreign
but you can't expect them to if you're
not going to give yourself that
me
are you in
yeah I'm definitely gonna try not to be
as mean to myself no no
better than that
I'm freaking Jade
and I want a reckless hilarious fun
marriage
drama free
I want a job that's not toxic
I want adult relationships that aren't
stupid
and I'm worth all that
Fair
what's your favorite charity in the
world like what's what's a what's a
thing that's near and dear to your heart
um the domestic violence awareness
do you have a local chapter there in
Raleigh
um yeah we do we have like a women's
shelter that usually helps them
okay
um
will you make me a deal here on the
radio
yeah say I promise
I promise oh this is amazing you're such
a sucker I can't believe you said yes to
this okay every time every time you talk
negative to Jade you have to send them a
dollar
every time
yeah I could do that okay
it's gonna cost you money
cool
yeah you have to put some roadblocks up
between your automated response
whether that's a behavior whether that's
an action whether it's grabbing a drink
or grabbing a cigarette or running away
and you're gonna ore between your
thoughts
here's a funny example it's not so funny
and I'm not proud of it but it just is I
um
I have a buddy who wants to drink less
and I have a like I eat way too much
junk food
so I put a thousand dollars on the table
one thousand bucks the first person
um he has a drink or if I grab junk food
a thousand dollars the first person to
Blink the other person's gotta pay
and I figured out really quickly I'm so
mindless I just reach over there's candy
everywhere here there's junk food and
donuts everywhere here at work and
everywhere I go my house it's Easter
good kind and I just grab it
and so I started to grab it one the very
first time right after I made this this
deal I reached over to grab it and I was
by myself and I just flipped it off
I gave it to bird
and then it made me laugh because I was
just trying to say like no I took a
picture of it and I texted it to him
and then every time I started mindlessly
grabbing it it was making me laugh I
would give it the bird and I'd take a
picture of it and text it to him
and in about a week
I quit grabbing it
what I needed was something just like
it's just called mindfulness I needed
something to stop my automated response
you suck
there's a dollar I'm Vin mowing the the
women's shelter
he's gonna get so mad if you there's a
dollar I'm sitting in the venmo I mean
I'm sitting in the shelter
I can't believe you're so stupid you're
late there's another dollar right I'm
gonna put these little roadblocks in
front of me
so that I can begin to catch myself in
this automated responses and you're
gonna have to decide I'm gonna quit
carrying this crap around
are you done carrying it Jade
yeah I really am I promise
I promise
tell this boy that you're dating
you're about to get a whole new woman
I'm gonna be fun and we're gonna be
goofy and we're going dancing
we're we're everything's changing
and it's gonna be a bumpy shot out of
the gate it's gonna we're gonna have to
figure this out and practice it but
we're changing it all we're changing all
of it cause I'm Jade and I want a
different world I want a different life
on a different life
if that means you gotta cut people out
of your life good that means you have to
add new people in your life good
whatever it takes Jade you're worth that
and
everything good you got coming for you
you've been through hell and back and
you got the scars
now I want you to stand up and realize
how strong and how tall you are
and how awesome whatever's coming next
can be
if you make some hard choices and some
hard changes you're worth it